sie machen Stimmung gegen den Westen
prominente rechtsradikale wie Markus
Beisicht wir dürfen in Deutschland nicht
länger Hampelmann der USA sein Schluss
mit dem deutschen
[Musik]
vasalentum die russische Propagandistin
Elen
kolbasnika warum sch du liebe
Z Islamisten wie Bernhard
Falk und das ist eine historische
Aufgabe die wir haben dass wir den
Russen die Hände
reichen und der frühere AFD
Spitzenfunktionär andre
Po
Freunde auf die können Sie
zählen alle gemeinsam auf kremmelkurs
alle Anhänger einer neuen Partei am 31
August gegründet derzeit rund 300
Mitglieder der Name Aufbruch Frieden
Souveränität
Gerechtigkeit Ramstein
Rheinlandpfalz wir haben erfahren hier
irgendwo unweit der Airbase soll die
neue Partei Aufbruch ihre Kandidaten zur
Europawahl nominieren alles
intern erst nach dem offiziellen Teil
teilt man uns mit wo wir hinkommen
sollen zu einem Gasthof wir treffen den
frisch nominierten Spitzenkandidaten
Markus Beisicht
organisationserfahrener rechtsradikaler
mit Vergangenheit bei der CDU den
Republikanern und pro NRW und wir
kämpfen gegen diesen amerikanischen
einheitsmensch der unsere traditionell
gewachsenen kulturellen Bindung
letztendlich zerstört und da steht
stehen wir natürlich für einen
Gegenentwurf und in diesem Gegenentwurf
spielt der russische Präsident
sicherlich auch eine Rolle für andere
Vorstandsmitglieder ist der russische
Präsident das politische Idol
schlechtthin wenn jemand über Diktatur
und Putin sagt da sind die Sachen die
kann man nicht
zusammenbinden hat so ein großer Herz
Wünsche das jedem so ein Herz zu
haben was von solchen Aussagen zu halten
ist erklärt uns der
Politikwissenschaftler Thomas
grumke er hat die Ideologie des Aufbruch
ausgewertet wenn wir uns den Bereich der
Ideologie anschauen dann haben wir es
hier mit einer gemeinsamen wirklich
tiefen Verachtung der freiheitlichen
Demokratie zu tun die wiederum ja ihren
Widerhall auch in im russischen Regime
findet man könnte sogar von einer gegen
Gegenbewegung sprechen gegen eben die
freiheitliche liberale moderne
Gesellschaft eben
ankämpfen einen Tag nach dem
listentreffen Protest in Rammstein die
USA als Feindbild rund 150 Menschen sind
gekommen um gegen die Stationierung
amerikanischer Truppen in Deutschland zu
demonstrieren prominent ist der Redner
an diesem Tag Andrej pogenburg früher
AFD Landesvorsitzender von SachsenAnhalt
und einer der Köpfe des rechtsextremen
AFD
Flügels die NATO ist
heutzutage nichts weiter als ein
aggressives als eine aggressive
imperialistische
beutegemeinschaft nicht mehr ist die
NATO
heute der Aufbruch ist eine
idealtypische Konstruktion des kremmels
in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland wenn
man so will erstens geht darum der
einheimischen russischen Bevölkerung
deutlich zu machen schaut her in
Deutschland gibt's starke Gruppen die
für uns einstehen zweitens haben wir mit
der Gruppe Aufbruch und vielen anderen
Aktivitäten Brückenköpfe in die deutsche
Gesellschaft und drittens geht's bei all
dem darum die politischen Verhältnisse
in Deutschland zu
destabilisieren ein solcher Brückenkopf
ist Elena kolbasnikovera die 48-Jährige
gelernte Finanzbuchhalterin gehört zu
den Aktivposten der neuen Partei
Aufbruch sie trommelt seit anderthalb
Jahren gegen deutsche Waffenlieferungen
an die Ukraine tausende Menschen
besuchen ihre Veranstaltungen wie hier
zum russischen Nationalfeiertag dem Tag
des Sieges über Nazi
[Applaus]
Deutschland im Laufe des Jahres 2022
wird der Ton schriller richtete sich die
Kritik von kolbasnik und ihren
Gleichgesinnten vorher nur gegen die
Unterstützung des Westens für die
Ukraine zielen sie jetzt auch gegen das
politische System in Deutschland unter
den Rednern wieder der frühere AFD
Landeschef Andrej poenburg außerdem Karl
Richter ein Publizist mit langer
Vergangenheit bei den Republikanern und
der NPD Richter ist inzwischen auch auf
der Europaliste des
Aufbruch Deutsche und Russen müssen
wieder zueinander finden um die Pläne
der amerikanischen Ostküste der
Transatlantiker zu hintertreiben und zu
Nichte zu
machen Frau analena
berb sie sind eine Gefahr für Europa
treten sie
zurück nehmen sie ihre ganzen
Volksverräter mit treten sie selbst
zurück bevor sie vom Thron gestoßen
werden erklärt Ziel des russischen
informationskrieges ist ja seit vielen
Jahren die
Verächtlichmachung des
liberaldemokratischen Systems per se ja
als dekadent als nicht zukunftsfähig da
sind natürlich besonders Menschen in
Europa die dann dort als Sprachrohr das
eben bestätigen besonders willkommen wir
treffen ein solches Sprachrohr es ist
juni
2023 auf Einladung des Aufbruch kommt
ein Gastredner nach leverkus
der zu den einflussreichsten Publizisten
am rechten Rand zählt Jürgen elsesser
dessen kompaktmagazin mehr als 40000
Abonnenten hat ein führender
rechtsextremer Ideologe und AFD
Unterstützer auf dem internen
aufbruchtreffen macht er sich seine
eigenen Gedanken über den Ausgang des
ukrainekrieges Situation wo das Volk die
MA
entsteht am een aus der
Kriegsniederlage wenn die NATO den Krieg
gewinnt dann sind wir dann
istust dann machen die uns z
zombieswegen muss die NATO verlieren
dazu muss man noch nicht mal Putin
Freund sein ich will es nicht laut sagen
aber ich freue mich über jeden
Leoparden
der
Luft für Susanne span gehört das zur
Taktik des Kremmel die Politologin
gehört zu den intimsten deutschen
Kennerinnen der russischen
Propagandamaschine das Interview mit ihr
müssen wir an einem anonymen Ort drehen
immer wieder Werte sie vom russischen
Staat
bedroht das ist der inliche der eben
diese Kräfte vereint hier das System
anzugreifen zum einen die politische
Ausrichtung also dass sie eindeutig
antiwestlich antiamerikanisch aber auch
tendenziell antidemokratisch eingestellt
sind also gegen unser System arbeiten
wollen und dann aber gleichzeitig damit
verbunden auch eine
unverholen zu Schau gestellte
Bewunderung von Putin als
führerommer 23 der Aufbruch ist in
Berlin Demonstration vor dem
Brandenburger Tor rund 300 Menschen
kommen mobilisiert haben jetzt auch
Islamisten wie Bernhard Falk mit
muslimischem Namen muntasier bila früher
vertrat der Position in der al-qider
Bewegung heute sieht er sich als Teil
einer antiamerikanischen Massenbewegung
an der Seite
Russlands man tituliert ein ja immer
wieder seitens der Medien als
vereh ich sage ganz deutlich ich bin
kein Putin versteher denn der braucht
keinen Psychologen sondern ich bin ein
Putin
unterstüzer und es kommen weitere
Unterstützer wieesl Sewald
kremmelpagandist auf telegram betreibt
er den sogenannten Putin Fanclub dem
mehr als 40 000 Menschen
folgent nicht Bor aber
gesellschalich war nicht also das
grundsätzliche Ziel
was ja auch eben der russische Staat
formuliert hat eben die deutsche
demokratische
liberaldemokratische Gesellschaft und
das politische System verächtlich zu
machen ist eben meiner Ansicht nach die
Hauptgefahr die hier im Raum steht der
Aufbruch Sammelbecken von Putin
Unterstützern Rechtspopulisten
Querdenkern und konservativ
ihr gemeinsames Ziel die liberale
Ordnung des Westens zerstören mit dem
Putin System als
Vorbild